what you're asked to show here is given
some point p any point p
normal through p intersects with the
axis at q here's the focus
and we want to prove this ratio this
distance here okay which is interesting
this is very close to the locust
definition of
the ellipse
it's not quiet because actually to do
with a different point anyway so
how are we going to go about this um
what i've found with most of the
conics question particularly for the
ellipse and the hyperbola is that
um algebra wise things can go bad very
quickly if you don't pick the right
approach okay whereas if you do it just
kind of falls out and then when someone
shows you the answer like ah why was i
going round and round in circles uh and
almost certainly the reason you were
going round and round in circles is
because um it's because of your approach
right it's like oh i use parametrics
when i shouldn't have or um i just was
trying to find the wrong distance first
and so when i was trying to find the
other distance it was very unclear what
i was trying to simplify toward that
kind of thing okay
so just before we actually put pen to
paper have a think about how you might
approach this
what's going to make this easiest for
you now keep in mind you've got the
focus there right and the corner to the
focus are
ae
okay so you've got that as something
which is kind of a
firm point and you're not going to be
changing that there's no other useful
way to express the focus
now
when you've got that in place that gives
you a bit of a clue as to how you might
want to express p because of course you
could just say it's any point x1 y1
right and that would work fine probably
but being that this is already in terms
of a and e right
it's in your interest to use the
parametric
expression for
the corner to this point can you see why
you see why because rather than saying
x1 y1 which is could be anything right
if i call this what are the coordinates
a
cos theta
b sine theta okay you see you've already
got two things in terms of a right so
things are going to have to cancel out
here when you're going from
q to s and then from theta s
i should have put that in as well
okay so those are the two distances that
i'm interested in right
now another quick question
clearly i'm going to have to work out
what q s and p s are which do you think
is easier to work out first
now just think about it for a second if
i were to work at qs first i would need
to know where q is right now thankfully
since it's on the axis it's just
something
zero right just like the focus is yes
but i don't know what the something is
just yet right and if i were to work out
the something
i'd need that equation pq wouldn't i and
then i'd have to substitute it in and
then i'd get a value now once i have
that it is very it's trivial to get that
distance qs because just the horizontal
distance that's fine
but i don't know what q is yet right so
that gives me an extra step before i can
work out qs
on the other hand
ps i already know where p is and where s
is so i can actually work out that
distance right away okay
so i think it's in my interest to work
that out and then when i go toward qs
i'll have an idea of what i'm
simplifying toward because i'm going to
have to show their
that ratio is true so they should be
very very close to each other the
expressions okay
so does that make sense you see how i'm
trying to plot out what direction i'm
going to go in so my algebra ends up
easier for me later on
so let's work out ps shall we
okay
it's just distance formula right so what
are you going to get
square root of
a cos theta
minus ae or squared
plus
and because it's zero there it's just
going to be b squared sine squared
right
okay now have a look at that
what kinds of things are going to be
useful to you here you've got this um
pythagorean identity thing happening
here right so it's probably going to be
useful to get as much of this together
and squared as i can okay so let me
express this
by i'll square it out and see what
happens
a squared cos squared
what i got here i've got
2 a squared e
cos
plus
a squared e squared plus
this
is that okay
yes now have a look at that with me
um you need some help before you get any
further in your simplification with this
right
you've got a's and e's and b's but you
guys know for any of these conic
sections that a's and e's and b's are
somewhat interchangeable because they're
all related right do you remember what's
the equation that relates all of them x
into c a and b should be
b squared equals
a squared outside off
good and of course if you were doing a
hyperbola and not an ellipse the
difference would be
that these are switched around okay
all right now the question is so let me
just expand that up a squared minus a
squared e squared
the question is how do you want to use
this right you can see you've got an a
squared e squared here you've got a b
squared there a squared there which
might be the most useful for you
hmm
i think i probably want to get rid of
this right it's the quickest way to get
rid of something i mean i could make a
squared e squared the subject right and
then replace this but then you're making
it worse not better i want to eliminate
variables out okay so if i take this
here
this is what i'm going to substitute in
right i'll get square root of that's a
long one a squared cos squared
2a squared e cos a squared e squared all
right here we go
a squared
sine squared
minus
a squared e squared
sine squared okay now even though it's
like i'm so sick of saying squared right
that's actually a good thing for you
right because
all of this we're going to take the
square root right and if i can get
everything in terms of something squared
then that'll be really nice i can get
rid of the square root
what can i do what can i do here what
kind of options do i have
okay so i can see a cos squared and a
sine squared here right so they're
actually just going to become
a squared okay right so i can do that
let's see here
drag this a squared e squared out in
front
what have i got here minus 2 a squared e
cos
i've accounted for this i've accounted
for this and i'll say plus a squared and
then i've got this guy
didn't need so much after all okay
can i do anything else here
okay
i can take out a factor of a square oh
sorry yeah i can take out a fact of a
squared here can't i so that gives me
let's see
a squared outside of
e squared minus
2 e
cos theta
plus 1 minus
e squared
sine squared there we go
how does that look
what else can i do here
remember i'm trying to eliminate things
out trying to get things in terms of the
same variables as much as i can right
this sine squared here surely i can do
something with this right it's easier to
do something with this than to do
something with this because it's squared
already right so what could i replace it
with
i could replace it with one minus cos
right
so i've got my
a squared out here e squared minus two e
cos theta plus one
minus e squared okay one minus
cos squared
yes
okay what's going to happen here
you've got a minus e squared here and an
e squared here right
you know i keep telling you colors
really help right so they're going to
cancel out that's nice
there right
then i'll have a minus e squared minus
cos squared so that's going to be plus
e squared cos squared right
okay so i've got a squared outside of
what did i just say e squared cos
squared
minus two e cos theta plus
one okay and now that should make you
look very suspicious right what can i do
with this
this
this is a square isn't it this is a
square here so this is the square root
of a squared
e cos theta
minus 1 because that minus sign right
minus 1
all squared
is that ok that's not bad hey right
so can i write this
i can almost write that can't i it's not
quite that's not quite
when you when you take the square root
of some
square number right
what's it going to be at the end well it
has to be can it be negative alpha
yeah
let me graph this thing square root
right looks like
this can it be negative
no it can't right we actually define the
square root that's as the positive value
it's just plus alpha in fact
this this here is one of the um
definitions for the absolute value of
alpha if you remember that okay so this
is actually this
which you might think that's a bit of a
pain but actually will be useful to us
later on okay so now i have an
expression for ps okay so
i'm going to keep that in the back of my
head right when i'm working toward
getting qs it's going to be in my
interest to simplify not just any random
direction you know how at this point
we're thinking what should i get rid of
right i now know exactly what i need to
get rid of when i'm working toward qs
right i ought to get
now what i'm required to prove
is that qs is e times this i want to get
to this
and i'm sure there are other ways to
express that distance qs but this is the
particular one i'm interested in does
that make sense
okay so that's what i'm trying to get at
can i rub this off or do people still
wanna okay now if you came late let me
just see if i can rehearse
what's going on in my head as i'm going
through this okay my first step was
step one and you might even like to do
this for yourself because it'll give you
an idea um where you're going and so you
don't get lost in the algebra
the first thing was work out distance
p yes okay that was the first thing
we're going to we did
now i need to work toward this so what's
my my intermediate steps between that
right well i'm going to have to work out
what equation pq is right so i'm going
to have to do that
once i've got equation pq what am i
going to do with it
i think what am i working towards i've
got to find where q is don't i right so
that'll be step three locate q
okay and the very last thing i can do
with that is work out the distance qs
and then i should be home
okay
um distance
yes
okay now do you need to write that of
course you don't need to write that okay
but does it help you not get lost in the
eyebrow it really does okay so
eventually you'll get to the point where
you'll be comfortable enough with these
conic questions where you can sort of
have that lodged in your head but until
then
just write it out so you know where
you're going and you're not like why
where what's my square root doing why am
i doing this which one am i choosing now
you know where you're headed right
okay what's the equation okay q what's
the what's the quickest way to get there
we do know the point that it's going to
right so all i really need to know is
the gradient through earlier right now
what's the gradient at p the gradient at
p what's it equal to foreign ellipse
feedback this is a result you need to
learn
i'll give you a tip it's a fraction
and it's negative
cinema
should be because on a sign
does that ring a bell yes
okay now we don't actually want the
gradient at p do we we want the gradient
perpendicular to p so we want the
gradient of the
normal
at p
okay which is just a matter of
flipping get rid of the minus sign right
um like so
yeah okay
so now surely i can work out pq pq i
know the point that it goes through so
there's y minus y
one
equals
m
uh this
times x minus x one
okay
now i could just leave it there right
but i want to work toward getting
q right so what form should i put this
in how should i simplify
what would you do
x axis right woohoo it's too early today
um i think the form i got in before was
this
i just kind of want the x out on its own
so i just multiplied through and i
simplified out some of my um some of my
fractions so i should end up with this
um
it takes a bit of getting there but i
think you'll
you've actually done
equations of normals and tangents sort
of to death so hopefully you'll be able
to get from here to here all right okay
now
i've done this
so now i need to do this how do i go
about doing that
you let
y equal zero right so for
coordinates of q
okay so what are we going to get here oh
that's right
it just disappears
okay now stop for a second remember the
whole reason we went for uh working out
ps first which i just hopefully rubbed
off didn't i i should have said that um
ps is equal to what we say absolute
value of
a
e cos theta minus one
there you go okay now that's what i'm
working toward and this is what i have
here
right
i can do better than this can't i i
don't want bees in there yeah so i can
replace that with something else
yes
what could i replace it with
i can replace it with a squared minus
a squared a squared right
minus this
oops sorry
is that okay but you can see the a
squared's just canceled so that gives
you this
okay what did i want uh i wanted x
didn't i right so i can cancel out an a
there so x should equal
a e squared
cos theta that's promising isn't it
think about what i have to get toward
okay so if that's what belongs here in
that blank i didn't really leave myself
enough space did i
um a e squared
cos theta
yeah okay so remember i said before
it should be trivial to get that
distance q s right how do i work out q s
now that i know the coordinate
hmm
now be careful right i think i think our
instinct is to say look a is bigger than
this right so i would say a e minus
a e squared cos theta okay
so you're like
okay okay hold on so that's what's that
i take out a factor of a e which gives
you this right and you get one there
and then you get e cos theta there now
is that what you were expecting
is it what you were expecting
you're like what oh what went wrong
it's very close isn't it
the e is where you want it to be because
it's e times the whole thing okay but
this thing is backwards right why is it
backwards
now at this point you might be tempted
to think oh uh i need it to be e cos
theta minus one
so i guess on this line i'll just turn
it around and i'll subtract the smaller
one from the bigger one except that kind
of
that should make you unsettled right
because you're like i'm trying i'm after
a distance here right i'm after bigger
minus smaller
what's the problem what's the problem
uh you guys know diagrams can be helpful
right the 99 of the time they're helpful
but sometimes they lead you in the wrong
direction okay because at the moment
i've drawn p such that it's normal goes
through there so q ends up on the left
of s
that point ends up on the left of the
focus but it doesn't have to be there
does it because p can be anywhere we
like right for instance if i put p
i don't know somewhere like here right
so where would its normal go through
it'll hit something like that so now q
will be over here right so actually q
can be anywhere you like you can't just
say it's this one minus that one you
have to be a you have to have a little
more finesse than that right
so in fact this here
should really be this
to account for the fact that it could be
on either side right
distance is what you get from absolute
value just like in complex numbers you
take the um the modulus it gives you the
distance okay
so that's that now
how does that change things
because i'm taking the absolute value of
this right i can actually multiply the
inside by negative one and it's fine
because eventually i'll take the
absolute value
this is the same as this
e cos theta minus 1. see that
i mean just to give you a simple example
the absolute value of 5 minus 2
is still the absolute value of 2 minus 5
because all i care about is the absolute
value the distance between them right so
that's why you're like that seems like
like magic you can just flip things
around because you want to no it's not
it's what happens if you understand
absolute value and that's equal to e
times ps
so there's your proof
okay